now Patrick I heard you say in another
interview that there's kind of a few
people that come out of film school
there's those that say oh I only want to
direct and they're like a 24 year old
kid and and that's a problem that self
but I want to talk about another problem
because you said there's people who work
as camera people or editors that boom
they find jobs right away but then a new
dilemma comes and that is they're paid
well and then they get trapped with
obligations a lifestyle and how do they
make that passion project or how do they
leverage all that into making this next
great film that they envision one and
that's their whole reason for coming to
LA or New York right and going to film
school so are there these is it only the
starving artists and the weekend
warriors that can actually do this or is
there a middle ground somehow that can
you mean actually do this by email like
make make a film for what do you say do
this yeah sorry I don't mean to be so
vague yeah I mean make a film and and
have it make some type of return yeah
because you do get trapped you get those
the good paying job and then you spend
more money yeah you want a nice
lifestyle it's understand I would say
that you know if making if making your
own films is important to you you gotta
keep that dream alive
it says horribly hokey as that sounds
it's really true I didn't come out you
know I grew up in Chicago I did not move
to Los Angeles to make corporate videos
I did not come here to shoot reality
television I did not come here to light
low-budget low-budget movies which all
of which I've done in my in my sort of
early career but I you know I realized
you know I went to the American Film
Institute I said I got out of school
when I came out about 20 years ago I've
been in LA almost 20 years now
for me job number one was just being
able to afford to stay out here paying
my student loans paying my rent paying
my insurance like I was on my own I had
to figure out how to do those things and
so I started I started as an electrician
and a best boy and a gaffer and did that
for about three years
met a lot of people learned a ton
figured out my way around town figured
out my way around this industry then I
went back to shooting and I said I'm not
gonna do any more lighting I'm just
gonna shoot shoot shoot as much as I can
I did that for another probably eight
years I would say in the meantime while
all this was happening Christine and I
got married we we bought a house we had
started our family which were all things
that I was not willing to sacrifice for
my film career I mean I wanted to have a
life too
right around 2004-2005 you know
Christine and I were in our 30s we had
built a life together that we that we
really loved and we kind of said you
know this is it this is the moment like
we're at a fork in the road either we're
gonna keep going down this road and make
other people's TV shows and movies or
we're gonna just pull the pull the plug
and just make our own stuff from here on
out and that's that's what we did and
that was that was when we started making
our first film wordplay and I you know I
really admire the moxie of a 22 year old
film school graduate who only wants to
direct and only wants to make movies and
if they can do that terrific every you
know once or twice in a generation
a Steven Spielberg is going to come
around a Steven Soderbergh is gonna come
around a Paul Thomas Anderson is gonna
come around and these are people who all
really made great films in their 20s but
then there's the rest of us and the rest
of us have to figure out a way to make a
living and you also have to really work
at your craft you know so I think that
studying any sort of discipline within
film school is is very very valuable in
my own experience I've seen that
studying camera which is what I studied
cinematography at the American Film
Institute or studying editing are two
really good places to begin because
those are the kinds of jobs that
production companies need to hire all
the time they need grips electrics and
camera ACS that's what the camera folks
are good at and they always need editors
and I and I have found at least at AFI
that the people who studied directing
the people who study screenwriting are
those are a little tougher to break in
on because not many people want to hire
a 25 year old screenwriter or a 25 year
old director by the way I would put
production design in that camp also of
of people who can get hired pretty
quickly because production departments
have very big teams and I I'm one of my
roommates in film school was a guy named
Todd chernow ski who's just really one
of the best art directors in Hollywood
and he was working from the day he got
out of school and hasn't stopped working
since so you know I I don't know I hope
that answers your question but I I don't
the last thing I want to do is sort of
discourage someone or make them feel
like it's harder than it's going to be
but I think the bottom line is if you
want to have a good career I think you
have to
patient I think you have to wait for the
for the right moment in your life where
you have a little bit of financial
stability and you have more importantly
you have confidence in your own
abilities to tell a story and when that
moment happens that's when I think you
should really strike and try to and try
to make make your first film make your
first television pilot make your first
you know whatever it is I think that's a
good moment in your life to really break
out on your own and I'll tell you one
thing that I've noticed because I I'm
weird like this but the more I've
studied other filmmakers the more I've
seen it's it's amazing
overwhelmingly the first-time filmmakers
tend to be in their mid to late 30s I've
seen that over and over and over and
over again I mean I remember reading
about Martin Scorsese when he turned 30
I don't think he had made his first film
yet and he was like devastated like oh
my god I'm washed up at 30 but a few
years later he started and he's done
fine yes I think that's gonna be okay
he'll be fine yeah so anyways
you